hey youtubers it's Charlie so we finally
know what's going on with the Deadpool
trailer we're gonna get it on Tuesday
it'll be full blown red band it's gonna
come on Conan that night so that'll
probably post online like right after
they air it on TV can you imagine like
if Conan was still doing this Tonight
Show there's no way they'd be able to
show that Deadpool trailer but he's on
TBS now so he can do almost whatever he
wants not anything but he can definitely
have a lot more fun what's probably
gonna happen is is it'll probably just
be the exact same trailer they showed
off a comic-con which is shiny or
special effects
the reason Ryan Reynolds said that they
didn't post it online yet that Fox
didn't post like the Deadpool trailer
after they aired it at comic-con is
because the effects weren't done yet
I've already done a breakdown to that so
I'll post a link in the description but
whenever they post the proper version
I'll just do another breakdown
explaining some of the stuff that they
changed so just set your calendars for
Tuesday nights I don't know why Tuesday
is like a big trailer days I'm guessing
people just feel like Tuesday is like
peak awareness time during the week or
something like that but here's an
explainer for the bigger side characters
that are gonna be in the Deadpool movie
Deadpool has a long history of really
awesome sidekicks some of the biggest
being spider-man in cable spider-man
obviously kind of locked down by a
spider-man in Sony so not expecting Tom
Holland to be in a Deadpool movie
anytime soon cables a little bit more
likely but he's supposedly not going to
be in this first Deadpool movie and no
matter what anyone says I don't think
this will be the last Deadpool movie you
know we really don't know what Ryan
Reynolds status with the franchise is he
said he's not gonna do a lot more
superhero movies after he's done with
this but Never Say Never
and even if he doesn't come back that
doesn't mean that the character is going
to be retired so these are just gonna be
side characters that are appearing in
the movie so that like I said you know
I'm not gonna talk about cable not gonna
talk about spider-man so starting with
the biggest one copycat played by Morena
Baccarin
who seems to be showing up everywhere
right now she's she's actually a series
regular on Gotham this season so if
you're a big fan of her just check out
Gotham season 2 but copycat is like a
really interesting character just
because the way she started out and in
the way that I think she's gonna be
portrayed in this movie probably
somewhat a little bit softer in the
movie she's a bit psycho whenever she
starts out in the comics she started out
about the same time Deadpool started out
their fictional character biographies
predate Deadpool becoming Deadpool when
he was still just Wade Wilson the
assassin she's a mutant
full mimicry abilities like she can
mimic other mutants powers she's kind of
like a more powerful version of mystique
like misty can look like other mutants
you see her make Wolverines claws but
the claws aren't real adamantium like a
copycat mimicked Wolverine she could
actually change her body to mimic
adamantium so she really would be just
as strong as Wolverine what I think is
gonna happen in the movie is is they'll
just they'll tune that down a little bit
but don't be surprised if you see her
mimic some badass power there was the
series called V that Morena Baccarin
played this like this lizard queen in
where she ate people but that that's
about as vicious as I've ever seen her
usually whenever she plays a character
they they tend to be a little bit
sweeter and softer so based on like the
stills in this movie it looks like she's
just up a little tripped out by the time
Deadpool becomes Deadpool but she's
gonna be one of the characters that'll
linked the film together just because in
the comics she's one of the characters
that links Deadpool's history his
present in his future in the comics she
was killed during Age of X she was
unmasked and killed by husk so we
haven't seen a whole lot of her recently
who knows if she shows up sometime
during Secret Wars
just because Marvel is bringing every
single character out of the woodwork for
the big secret wars crossover in their
tie-ins she has never appeared in one of
the x-men films before but her name
appeared on a list during x-2 so you
know small Easter Egg for copycat Morena
Baccarin will be the first time that
she's like she fully features an actual
character in the film but the last big
copycat art like if you want to read
like a like a bunch of copycat stories
is Age of Apocalypse the classic Age of
Apocalypse and I know they're doing like
an age of apocalypse time during Secret
Wars it's a little bit weird so you can
try that too but I'd recommend reading
the classic Age of Apocalypse first by
all accounts though consider her an ally
just a really crazy al I expect Eric
Turner number two weasel being played by
TJ Miller in the movie you might not
remember his name but he was in the last
Transformers movie as the sidekick to
Mark Wahlberg of sorts
he's on Silicon Valley on HBO right now
he's actually he's kind of a know
annoying character but that's that's who
he plays he's just really good at
playing annoying characters his voice is
instantly recognizable so whenever I
heard he was in the film I was a little
bit worried but really it's his job to
make
pool scene cooler because typically
Deadpool is the one that's annoying in
any group of characters like whenever
the x-men are standing around Deadpool
is the one that's cracking wise like you
know poking fun at people
he's like the Loki of the group so how
do you make him seem more badass you
bring in someone else to out wisecrack
Deadpool and and that's probably what
weasel is gonna be doing in this film
unless they go dramatically off type for
TJ Miller in the comic books weasel
actually started out going to the same
high school as spider-man and Mary Jane
he even competed with Peter for a job at
Oscorp his real name is jackhammer and I
know how funny that sounds but in this
really funny twist of fate
Deadpool actually comes back in time and
tells Norman Osborn the jackhammer that
weasel is like a drug abuser so Norman
Osborn fires him from Oscorp and he ends
up turning to a life of crime which
which throws him into the path of
Deadpool in the future so this is future
Deadpool messing with weasels past and
even though their friends Deadpool
abuses him pretty regularly so don't be
surprised if you see Brian Reynolds
slapping around TJ Miller in the movie
for the most part his character is kind
of like an evil Oracle like at like a
support character that provides weapons
and information to mercenaries like
Deadpool and other villains anybody
that's willing to pay his fee next big
character number three Ajax very
important to the transition from Wade
Wilson becoming the Deadpool character
taking on the persona he is a very very
evil person he's being played by ed
skrein in the movie if you know he's
actually the new transporter in the new
transporter film series the character
debuted inside dr. kill Bruges lab which
was kind of like a place where cast offs
from the Weapon X program went like if
they got washed out of the Weapon X
program they would try and bury him at
this research facility where dr.
Killebrew unbeknownst to the Weapon X
people would continue performing really
evil experiments on them Killebrew
modified Ajax to give him enhanced
strength he dead in his nerve so that he
could take a bigger beating and he had
super speed and super basic elite just
upping him closer to the level of
Deadpool making making him a worthy
opponent for Deadpool so he is
definitely going to be fighting Ryan
Reynolds in this movie in the context of
the comics he was really only around for
Deadpool's origin story if he dink
deadpool's acid
to character though Ajax just like takes
that to the nth degree it's really
interesting to see like all the
different characterizations for Deadpool
in the comics just depending on the
supporting cast that they give him it's
like how do you make one of the most
sadistic characters in Marvel Comics
seem funny or seem sympathetic well you
just put like really really terrible
characters around him mixed up negasonic
teenage warhead being played by brianna
hildebrand in the movie I'm so I'm so
excited about her she'll be one of his
true sidekicks that that's why she
appears in like all the posters with him
she was a really big character an
astonishing x-men she most people know
her as one of Emma Frost students and is
a member of the Hellfire Club so she's
like a really dark version of one of
Professor X's students just like Emma
Frost she has a level of telepathy but
for the most part her powers give her
premonitions like she sees visions of
the future usually when you see
characters like that show up in movies
they give them premonitions of their own
death they're like you if you go into
this situation you're gonna die so you
can see how a character like Deadpool
with infinite regeneration would react
to situations like that he'd just be
like okay no big deal I'll just I'll
grow whatever body part I lose back next
big character angel dust I know this is
getting really fun she's being played by
Gina Carano in the movie probably a
relatively minor appearance but she is
in the movie if you're a big fan of the
flash she was actually created by geoff
johns in the comics which i think is
really funny
geoff johns did write for Marvel comics
before he came to DC the team that she's
most associated with though is the
Morlocks who are actually appearing in
x-men apocalypse even though there's
there's not gonna be like a lot of
crossover in Deadpool Deadpool is a
spinoff from the x-men franchise but I
don't expect a whole lot of that story
to be referenced in the Deadpool movie
her powers give her the ability to
increase her adrenaline so she gains
superhuman strength for short durations
of time so just expect a really scary
version of Gina Carano smashing the
out of stuff I feel like gina carano
needs to be in more to these movies just
because she's such a badass in the
comics she's mostly a good character
they're just living in a really bad
situation so she's not gonna be like an
evil person in the movie but that
doesn't mean that she won't be fighting
Deadpool and finally one of the bigger
characters Colossus going to be in the
movie but not the Colossus from the
x-men franchise that we've seen
so you probably actually know quite a
bit about a colossus just because he's
been in so many of the cartoons and so
many of the movies so he's like he's one
of the more known characters mostly
characters that we'll see in the
Deadpool movie or relatively obscure
from a comics standpoint just because
they're not quite as mainstream as the
x-men characters that we've seen in
those x-men movies the really cool thing
that they've done with his character
though in the Deadpool movie is make him
even bigger like this is a picture of
him behind the scenes that I mean
they're gonna full full blown CG him
just because those powers require that
but I think they recast him just so that
he towers over Deadpool a little bit
more so he'll look even more badass than
he's looked in Bryan Singer's x-men
films it was even this story line called
Deadpool I'm available where he ends up
killing Colossus I don't know
necessarily this gonna be the
relationship in the movie because
Colossus is a good character so they'll
probably be fighting just because of
this scene on the bridge here but they
might end up coming together to defeat
Ajax at the end of the movie they
wouldn't put Colossus in the movie if he
wasn't an important character like it's
it's not just like a very brief
appearance so expect his relationship
with Deadpool to be fairly significant
and just because I don't want to leave
her out blind al is also in the movie
she's one of Deadpool's biggest
characters like in in terms of his
origin story her name is really Althea
she appeared in his very first
self-titled issue whenever he got his
own title Deadpool number one she's this
really curious blind old woman a lot of
people thought that she might be
Deadpool's mother for a while her true
origin is never revealed so she's
something of like a mystery character
but he was hired to kill her under
mysterious circumstances when he was
still Wade Wilson but before he got
cancer and before he became the Deadpool
character so he spares her and then
later when he becomes Deadpool he meets
her again and it's after that that
they're like the really bizarre
relationship begins so even though
Deadpool continues to keep her a captive
she plays something of like a like a
mother figure in his life whenever she
debuted the the writer Joe Kelly
actually intended for her to be the
first black widow but that Marvel Comics
is played with a lot of continuity in in
that Natasha Romanoff is the original
Black Widow so a lot of that got swept
under the rug but it's implied that
blind al is like a really big part of
the historical Marvel Universe like
supposedly she even dated Captain
America in the 1940s she's actually a
really important characters
right so I'd recommend just reading that
original Deadpool run to get a sense for
her character here's my big question for
you guys like what psyche character in
this Deadpool movie are you most excited
to see I would say you know most people
probably gonna be excited to see blind
al in copycat but there's just there's
like so many things to be pumped about
Colossus is gonna be badass he's gonna
have a crazy fight with Ajax
but once you guys see this red band
trailer you'll poop your pants it'll be
a lot of fun so just remember that's
coming on Tuesdays so that's when my
video is gonna post for that if there
are any other Deadpool related videos
that you guys want me to do just let me
know in the comments and I'm actually
just gonna start my Marvel giveaway now
so all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video I'll announce the winner whenever
I post that Deadpool trailer video so in
case you guys didn't see it during the
the week of Comic Con when I posted it
you can click here for a description of
that Comic Con footage I just did like a
breakdown of it and you can click here
for my breakdown to the x-men apocalypse
footage thank you so much for watching
everybody let's have five I'll see you
guys tonight
you